[Musik]
etwas faul ich kann das nicht benennen
treffpunkt für alle vertreter der
rechtsextremen szene nichts gegen polen
rumänien oder einen positiven gegen
jemanden der es klang damals haupt sehr
harmlos aber ich habe zu mir gesagt mehr
das kann gefährlich werden die andere
position und die von eben wir das sind
diese 20 prozent in der bevölkerung die
rassistisch eingestellt sind
die sind jetzt sichtbar auf der straße
ja es gibt sie noch immer noch
demonstriert peggy dann montags oder
jeden zweiten montag und noch immer
bestimmen sie das stadtbild und das bild
der stadt begeht auf der einen seite die
gegendemonstranten auf der anderen seite
es ist schon ein fast ritualisiert des
verhältnisses montags in dresden
hier bin ich groß geworden und peggy da
auch seit 2014 schon laufen sie durch
dresden was hat das mit meiner heimat
gemacht und was mit der gesellschaft
warum gibt s p da immer noch die
versuchung holen wo unsere interessen zu
vertreten
hallo gast das land wir uns in berlin
erhalten
vielleicht im leben das hat dann eine
gewisse gewohnheit auch mit dabei man
kennt man hier viele und wir sind dran
da hat man die zeit fertig für mich war
peggy dann falls eine von vielen
diffusen demos damals in der stadt was
sich daraus entwickeln würde war im
herbst 2014 noch unklar
doch es gab vorahnungen damals waren nur
350 leute da ich fand erster
gegendemonstrant kann man heute so
bezeichnen
und da war dann plakaten die gingen mehr
oder weniger und existenzangst wir
bekommen kein gehör von politiker die
uns gewählt haben
am rande gab es dieser bezeichnung
islamisierung des am landes und da habe
ich gesagt wäre den anfänger es ist auch
eine zeit gewesen wo man mit einer
anderen hautfarbe mit einem anderen
aussehen
angst hat den appetit an demonstrationen
peggy da konnte seine teilnehmerzahl in
der anfangszeit wöchentlich verdoppeln
teilweise ging 20.000 menschen auf die
straße hier am rande der dresdner
innenstadt versammelte sich peggy da die
ersten male und wurde schnell zum
dauerthema egal ob am arbeitsplatz am
küchentisch oder in der straßenbahn
überall wurde über peggy diskutiert und
darüber wie man sich dazu positioniert
mit peggy dafür dresden unter ein neues
ein düsteres licht dunkel deutschland
hieß es auch ich musste mich ständig für
meine heimatstadt erklären
peggy da war voll im medialen fokus das
pegi da dadurch unnötig groß gemacht
würde war ein vorwurf dass die
berichterstattung zu aufgeregt zu wenig
differenziert war auch in dresden oder
auch insgesamt hat ist glaube ich habe
da aber auch eine positive folge gehabt
wenn man so will plötzlich gegen es halt
auch darum zu diskutieren was bedeutet
eigentlich demokratie für uns irgendwann
in dialog zu treten die nachhaltigste am
ende war es noch mal eine andere frage
gegenprotest den gab es in dresden immer
und doch steckt er häufig in sinnkrisen
mitunter stellten sich nur 20 menschen
per liga entgegen
mittlerweile werden es wieder mehr es
sind vor allem junge demonstrantinnen
und demonstranten die ich beim protest
erlebe und eine band mit kontinuität und
kreativität haben sich daran gewöhnt da
ist also ich vermisse tatsächlich das
bürgerliche lager hier ist ein ganz
normaler menschen mit kindern ich da
wird ein bisschen rentnerinnen und
rentner
ich habe hier von super touristen aus
hamburg getroffen
ganz ehrlich kein schwein weiß wer das
ist dieses fach andres noch gibt ja aber
wir müssen damit leben seit sechs jahren
und die frage ist natürlich warum in
dresden warum es immer noch da
das frage ich mich auch und begleiter
eine pg das safari
normalerweise geht es bei stadtführungen
ja um attraktionen das pegi dazu einem
besichtigungs würdigen bestandteil
dresdens geworden ist scheint mir
erstmal mag aber doch das kulturbüro
sachsen ein verein der sich seit 20
jahren mit rechtsextremismus in sachsen
beschäftigt setzt sich in einem rundgang
kritisch mit peggy da auseinander
es ist auch heute noch so wenn die kita
vom altmarkt ihre runde über dr külz
ring läuft das man dann sieht alle
menschen die quasi pius ii sind frauen
mit kopftüchern dann wäre es gibt es
riesengroße abschiebe absaufen rufe also
es ist sofort eine rassistische stimmung
der rundgang thematisiert auch
ausschreitungen vor den toren dresdens
in heidenau freitag und bomben anschläge
auf moscheen in der stadt
die täter liefen bei peggy damit waren
teils sogar redner und welche rolle
spielt peggy da aktuell diese diese
demonstration dienen für bestimmte
führungsfiguren aus afd und anderen
rechten kreisen durchaus als so eine
bühne um dinge auszutesten also kalbitz
ist hier aufgetreten vor wenigen wochen
als er schon aus der afc ausgeschlossen
war
gleichzeitig sind mal wieder auf die
leute da und man testet so ein bisschen
wie kommen denn die parolen an wie
reagiert das volk und so weiter also es
ist schon so ein testballon dieser
demonstration das was ich ringsherum
geschaffen hat damit werden wir noch
jahrzehnte beschäftigt sein
ich versuche mit peggy die
sympathisanten zu sprechen möchte wissen
was ihre meinung nach bei giga in sechs
jahren erreicht hat
sehr viel sind würden die linken und die
bergen noch mehr denn deutschland kann
man nochmals genau das ist hat sich
nicht viel verändert weil unsere eliten
haben das geld gemacht so wie in berlin
und nordrhein westfalen
wie sich gewisse dinge doch gern dass
politiker sagen
ein punkt den ich zustimmen muss was in
sechs jahren in rehden bei peggy da in
immer neuen provokation stufen gesagt
wurde wurde zu etwas sagt barren der
hass auf das system auf die da oben das
ist ja nicht mehr nur noch was man mal
wieder wird man hört es halt in einer
sehr breiten gesellschaft das hat sich
reingefressen gesellschaft nicht nur in
sachsen oder im osten von deutschland
ist auch woanders man hört es
tatsächlich auch jetzt bei den corona
demonstrationen wir erleben eigentlich
gerade eine art best pick ida die sich
entwickelt also ist es nicht nur ein
problem von hier und da ist die genau
dieselbe sprache die angewandt wird die
sich halt immer weiter es hat sich halt
immer weiterentwickeln und ich glaube
das ist die gefahr auf die man schauen
muss und die man halt ernst nehmen muss
man daraus eben immer menschen sich
radikalisieren können und auch zu tätern
werden können
in meiner heimat wurde peggy dazu einer
rechten protestbewegung wie sie nie
zuvor gegeben hat und über einen nie
dagewesenen zeitraum konnte sie dresden
als hauptstadt des widerstands
instrumentalisieren und rechte netzwerke
bilden
vor allem aber wurde in sechs jahren
sichtbar was in der gesellschaft
schlummert
sechs jahre peggy da das hat folgen
nicht nur für die stadt dresden auch für
die gesellschaft und auch dann wenn
peggy danach diesem jahrestag der
wahrnehmung in der öffentlichkeit weiter
laufen wird
[Musik]